i was driving last i haven't i can't
remember last time i drove at night once
i'm home from the studio i'm [ __ ]
home but i had a meeting last night
and i was driving at night and all all
lights had like a
halo around them like all lights were
like my eyes were not
20 20 at night i think because i had
that lasik eye surgery when i was like
23. you got to get it done everything
either you got to get done or i think i
need nighttime glasses
why not you wear it uh i only wear
eyes probably wear my glasses all the
time but i don't
i think i need to go get my eyes checked
out because i was driving i'm like what
the [ __ ] is it you know sometimes it's
like all starry
yeah because i i can usually since i was
a kid i can tell
cars from their headlights yeah i'm like
i know that's a ferrari 488
i know that is i'm like what's wrong
with the lights because they were like
all weird looking
and i drove them i got to 48 i'm like oh
it's not the car it's my [ __ ]
eyes i started looking at other cars i'm
like oh my eyes are [ __ ] up gotta go
get a check yeah
and i was also like damn it's [ __ ] i
think your lace if you do legit you have
to go like every
two years or five years i did it no
every 10 years
i think 10 sounds more normal every two
would be a nightmare but uh oh is it
tough
no it does i think it is every two years
that'd be a bad idea and it's like
i remember in venice beach i saw a sign
said lasik 9.99
e no one i wouldn't do one i get the
other one
free what a guy are you so
brother trying to make it oh no this is
like every ten years
so it is every ten years yeah that's
what it says
i need retreatment you know what i i
don't want to do it i just want to get
uh
i won't i want a reason to wear glasses
you know what you know what are your
glasses prescription chin are those for
screen but they're very very light
prescription it's bifocals too
yeah oh they aren't yeah these are for
reading these are for distance
oh i need that i should probably do that
but i feel like yeah but i feel like
i look i can see further away fine but i
need this to read
and my eyes got way worse than the last
like two years so when you're in your
40s
that's when it starts 37 doug
wow what the [ __ ]
no man that's not original
they look cool dude yeah yeah you do
kind of look like a general person
it's like superman when he takes off his
glasses and has a little like hair thing
yeah like you look different i i do you
you look like security for a handleable
birth
yeah i'll take that
it's good do they help you yeah he's a
great guy yeah does it help your eyes
oh my god it's like weird like close
great but like distance it's weird you
look like oldest from martin
martin a little bit yeah or the best
friend from
get out get out yeah the best friend the
security guard
oh he's talking about a little real yeah
yeah
is that me yeah that's you dog
here let me we're gonna take a picture
yeah you know i do this
by side by side picture yeah i do oh
you do look like hannah but yeah try to
tell me that isn't chappelle
yeah that is do a true
by side pick again that is you damn you
found your doppelganger
is it me yeah bruh does he oh i see what
you're saying chin like
it's uh different yeah oh god i got it
yeah like
yeah okay you'll be a great tsa too i
can just tell
i would kill that tears dude i killed it
at valet they loved me in valencia you
can you just ballet and velman
i would get the nice like uh reviews for
people man
any job i would ever that i ever seen
you have another pair there yeah
of course um i have only so i have the
you know the bottom
part of the bifocals that's what these
are but they're their entire
hey but when i look down they're great
yeah see that's that's what
wow oh because you like the ti do you
think you want a thick frame like that
i just i don't know i don't know he's
got to pull it up maybe we should both
go we should both go it's been it's been
i haven't got my eyes checked since like
last night was scary when i was driving
home like oh this ain't good yeah this
is great
yeah i just see clearly like look at i
can see
because there's no way that lasik can
only affect me at night it has to affect
me during the day too i just don't
realize it yet
maybe it's because because your eyes are
getting a little worse and then
nighttime it's harder to see
this fog yeah it's not
how old are you yeah i'm 28. i just
figured
out your eyes great junior 40 i just
turned 43.
you
well first of all kiss my ass for the
way you took that picture
bro that's how you look
right he made me look like that huh
that's how you look
hey what what i say in the group text
yeah how long will you pretend
chappelle's not the thickest one
let me try those glasses i'm not the
biggest one do you think it's one item
yeah not a bus
chef you can't i say you or jay
jay-z jason jason look at that with a
chain
yeah he's trying to make me look like
that and they look down
like if you're trying to read your phone
you look like that girl from recess
did she not have glasses i thought she
had glasses oh wait i don't know
oh all right well all right well again
we tried most people think i look like
doug
o'faroo
that's what you look like well there's a
there they were going to redo doug
pepperman patty was a baddie i give some
currents man
all right man those kind of [ __ ] my
eyes up jen
did they really they're super super weak
though i know
i should probably yeah i should i gotta
read i gotta
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son